- I'm fucking working around here.
(rock music)
- [Driver] Good morning.
- Morning.
- [Kyle] Good morning.
- Good morning vlog, seven a.m.,
headed to Jersey for a
two hour client meeting
and heading back to the city.
All day meetings till about 10 p.m.
Last night I went to Cleveland.
I had a great time at the
Cavs game, Cavs, Celtics.
Big shout-out to Gordon Hayward.
I'm so sorry about your injury man.
I hope you get better.
It was super-gruesome.
You saw that Kyle?
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Yeah, wild.
Big love to everybody.
I hope everybody has a
great productive day.
It's gonna be another grinder.
Just kinda how it is.
Day in the life, most
of them aren't pretty.
(mellow music)
- [Kyle] I thought that's
just super-fascinating.
- That is interesting.
That's actually exactly right.
The context.
- [Kyle] How was the workout this morning?
- Good, I got home late last
night since I was in Cleveland
so it was mainly low rolling
session this morning but good.
- [Kyle] How many days a
week do you usually go?
- Every.
- [Kyle] Everyday?
- Workout everyday, seven days a week.
- [Kyle] Do you like
going seven days a week?
Like to you feel pumped in the morning?
- Yeah, I like to,
I just need to not break
the pattern, you know?
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Even if it's a day like today.
(mellow music)
Love this.
Love the green, love
this, love the cork top.
Inside, these are super rad.
What do you think Kyle,
you gonna get a pair?
- [Kyle] Of course.
- Yes!
Accidents, traffic, I hate
being late for meetings
but some things you can't control.
(mellow music)
Meeting time.
Please don't film here.
I can fit one, two.
I can fit two.
Okay, that was fun.
Do you want a seatbelt?
Jeff, are you wearing a seatbelt?
- [Jeff] Of course.
- Thank you.
This is why this whole
thing's gonna work for us.
Every time somebody cares
about their money, we win.
As I embark on my fifth business book
and because five is my favorite number,
I just want to make sure
I acknowledge the team,
the thing, that I most value in the world,
which is my family.
From my amazing wife Lizzie,
and my amazing kids Misha and Xander,
to my unbelievable
parents, Sasha and Tamara,
and the rest of my siblings and in-laws
and brother and sister in-laws.
I'm only able to live this anomaly
because of the infrastructure and the love
that you guys support me with.
And so I thank you from
the bottom of my heart.
And this is dedicated to all the people
that are brave enough to attempt
the ability to go out and live their life
and actually recognize the
enormous opportunity we all have
in this new digital age to
have a balance of happiness,
not only in their life, but in their work.
Cool.
(gentle music)
Kyle, you're not getting much.
It's just been meeting after meeting.
Just keep B-rolling the
fuck out of this vlog.
I'll figure out how to make this
an entertaining episode for you
but I'm fucking working around here.
(mellow music)
(upbeat music)
What's up vlog?
As you could tell by the B-roll
that Kyle's gonna bang out,
today was an obnoxiously busy day.
I did a bunch of 90 day reviews.
Every 90 days I get
together with my, Anna!
Hi!
- [Anna] How are you?
- Vlog, this is Anna, one of
my favorite, favorite employees
at VaynerMedia, six years?
- Hello, six, five
years, five years, yeah.
- Five, five, feels like six.
- I just came from gym guys.
- Do you think it's weird
that you'll be on the vlog
in your kind of gym, red faced out.
- I'm just out of gym
class, like two seconds.
- Did you kill it?
- Yeah.
- [Reeva] It felt good.
- Hi.
- This is Reva.
- Hi, Reva.
- Reva, how are you?
- Good nice to meet ya.
- Pleasure, good to see you.
You well?
- Yeah
- Are you gonna ever say hi to me or?
- Yeah.
- This is my open door policy issue
that I've been talking about.
I need to see you more often.
- Okay, I'll see you tomorrow.
- You always promise and you never do.
- Well I'm still mad.
- Please, you good?
- Yeah.
- All well?
- Good, awesome.
- Alright, bye.
- Yes?
- Oh bro!
- How are you?
- I love listening to your stuff, man.
- Thank you brother.
- Can I get a quick picture?
- Of course.
Love it man.
What's your name?
- Steve man.
- Steve thanks for the love.
- Thank you so much for
posting everything you post
and all the things you say.
- Thank you brother.
I wish you well.
Okay, got it.
So busy day, all day.
Every 90 days I get together with my team,
da, da, da, da, da.
Lots of stuff, client
stuff, great day, super-busy
and so what I want to do
is I want to set up this talk I gave
at Bloomberg for Cornell Tech.
Very much the state of the union
of a lot of thoughts on my mind.
A lot of things that are
going on with the tech space,
the entrepreneur space, the
attention of consumer space,
engaging with your employees, Anna,
engaging with people that are
consuming your content, Steve.
I'm mean just super-interesting stuff.
I hope you enjoy it.
One of the sharper kind of
different angled fireside chats
that I've done in a while
and I hope you sit back,
pop a glass of red wine and watch this.
- Gary.
- Yes?
- Very straightforward,
let's start with
uncovering your strengths.
Lots of people want to be
Gary Vee, but they can't.
So let's talk about self
awareness and when you figured out
that you are an exceptional communicator.
- You know, not until later.
I think it's funny, lots of
people want to be Gary Vee.
I think lots of people want to
really figure themselves out
and put them in a position
to be happy and successful.
So when I hear that,
I mean I don't think a lot
of people want to be me.
I think I put myself really out there
and a lot of baggage comes along with that
and so I think
personalities are different.
But it's interesting to think
about your circumstances.
I was 31 years old running
a retail e-commerce wine
business in New Jersey.
I'd never been to Silicon Valley.
A lot has happened very quickly
on the back of me understanding
where consumer tension is.
And probably about a year
into Wine Library TV,
in 2006 I started a wine
video blog show around wine
on YouTube in YouTube's really early days
and about six months in I'm like wow,
a lot of people are watching this
and it was because I
was talking about wine
in a very different way
and I genuinely believe
a lot of entrepreneurs
and people listen to me because
I think I'm undereducated in some ways.
You know I don't know the way a lot
of things are said or done,
because I was very much a street
immigrant kind of kid more.
I wasn't a good student
and I just kind of look at things
a lot of times for the first time, right?
And I think someway, somehow,
and because my Mom's Dad
basically only spoke in analogies
from what my Mom talks about him
and I do that quite a bit.
I feel like, you know my Dad doesn't talk.
- What do you mean he doesn't talk?
- So my Dad and I drove
45 minutes to Wine Library
and back when I was a teen.
Shoppers Discount Liquors back in the day.
I lived in Hunterdon County, New Jersey
for my high school years
and my Dad's wine store was
in Short Hills, Millburn,
so it was 45 minutes
on Route 78 in Jersey.
And we would drive all the
way there and all the way back
and I talked every minute
and my Dad didn't say a word.
(audience laughs)
So my Dad's an old-school Russian guy.
You know in Russia, Communist Russia,
you didn't talk because
if you said something
that somebody found out, you went to jail.
I mean like let's get to the punch line.
There's a lot of reasons
my Dad doesn't talk.
But yeah, being in a setting like that
where you're building something
in a business environment together
but somebody's not
communicating back to you
definitely honed, I think,
intuitive skills I already had,
improv skills I already had.
They probably made them hyper and yeah.
At this point I really understand it
but I'm really bad at cheering
things or observing them.
Like I do them in real time.
There was never a point where I sat down
and thoughtfully was like wow,
I have this or this is important.
I'm aware of it.
I try not to get too high or too low
about any of these things,
but it's definitely a
disproportionate impact on my career,
but not only as the public persona,
on the one-to-one relationships
I have with my employees
and my family members.
Being a good communicator is
a pretty fruitful skill set.
- And as Dan was saying,
you learn by doing
and you've formed multiple businesses.
This communications skill
has allowed you to do this
from Wine Library, to VaynerSports,
to the host of multiple digital programs.
Which of these different businesses
do you do for love versus for money?
- I speak for love.
I do this for love.
Like this is the place I love the most.
Public speaking is now an
ROI negative event for me
with the things that
are going on in my life,
even though it is still crazy to me
what I get paid to do a speech.
You know, especially when you
come from zero, it's you know.
Getting paid to give a
speech one day this year,
making more money than I
made when I was 30 years old,
is a pretty intense kind of thing
that you'd wrap your head around,
but it's still not worth my
time in a lot of ways now
unless it's leading to business generation
for VaynerMedia or other things,
which is really what I've now mainly do.
But I'll do something in New York
or support organizations I believe in.
But I do this for love.
I love the thought that,
like so knowing all of,
so I love reverse
engineering the audience.
So I'm in a very funny zone
right now in this talk.
In this talk it's less
about entertainment,
like 18,000 people at a
off-site for a company.
Tonight's about okay, I
really want to be sharp
and talk about three or
four things that I think
even a really strong crowd like this
isn't thinking enough about,
because I'm always trying to
leave with giving more value
than the person expected, right?
So this I do for love.
The Gary Vee thing, the public persona,
I think I do for love the most.
- Okay, VaynerSports?
- VaynerSports is a business
that is very interesting
because my brother has Crohn's disease
and so he left VaynerMedia two years ago
because the stress of
going from 30 to 800 people
was pretty intense and he
just didn't like it anymore.
And if anybody here is in client service,
you're just managing people,
and if you don't like managing
people, it sucks shit, right?
And so he got to that place
and he needed to bounce
and he needed time for himself.
And very quickly he came back
and said "What about that
sports agency we bought?"
I bought a sports
agency, a very small one.
Just to learn, you know.
I have very substantial ambitions
to buy the New York Jets.
(audience and host laughing)
So I figured if I own a
sports agency I'll learn.
I'll learn from the inside.
I was gonna lose money every year
owning a boutique sports agency
that I wasn't going to be
really involved with, to learn.
But then he wanted to do that
and once he decided he
wanted to really be involved,
I felt comfortable in
rebranding it to VaynerSports,
putting our name on it.
It was gonna be real.
I love it.
I mean I'm talking to 50 of
the top 100 football players
that are gonna come into the
NFL next year on DM right now.
It's fun, I like it.
It's interesting.
It's an awful business, makes no sense.
It's the stupidest business going.
Like just a terrible business
model, sports agencies.
You have to have unbelievable scale
for it even to become
somewhat interesting.
My brother's doing it for love.
I'm doing it for the love of my brother.
- Now your philosophy as you pursue
all these different avenues
is that nine to five,
working nine to five is for losers.
If you want to be productive (laughing).
- Not true.
- Well it's for someone
who isn't gonna get
where they want to get.
- No, and I appreciate you bringing it up.
And listen, The Times razzed
me the other day on this
in a pretty substantial way.
When I talk about things, context is lost.
Sometimes I'm at fault,
sometimes people that
report on it are at fault.
To make it very clear, here's my thing.
I'm fascinated by people that complain.
If you don't complain,
I actually have nothing to say to you.
I don't think I'm entitled to.
You clearly have no
reason to really listen.
If you're good, you're good.
And if that's nine to five,
and you're on four softball teams,
and you're loving life, then you won.
My big thing is in this
era of everybody saying
that they're gonna be billionaires
and they're entrepreneurs
and they're the best and I'm
the next fucking Zucks, right?
And you're going to Coachella,
and you're going to every Summit at Sea,
and you're just not working,
like you might think that's intriguing.
I don't think people are losers.
I don't think people shouldn't sleep.
I think you're actions
should match your mouth
and your ambitions.
That's what I'm interested in.
And I think that we have a
very broken system right now
of entrepreneurial tendencies
because there's a lot of money
in the system and it's
a very intriguing time.
So I think working nine
to five is for a loser
that says that they're
gonna rule the world
and they watch Netflix
for four hours a day.
- But if you want to
start your own business,
if you want to be the next Gary Vee,
it takes more than working nine to five.
You gotta put in the time,
you've got to hustle.
- I think so.
I think it's super hard to build
a substantial, sustainable,
safe business working nine to five if,
I mean look, let me say it again,
you can work nine to five.
You really can.
I just think that hard work
is an unbelievably controllable variable
compared to the serendipity
of the marketplace,
the God-given talent you have.
You see it's a very important variable
that I think is a differentiator
if you want to be successful
and I see a lot of people
resting on their laurels
after they hit some success in their past.
And what I'm worried about
is technology's created infrastructure
that has not allowed us
to rest on our advantages,
not even the biggest
companies in the world.
The biggest retailers in the world,
the biggest media companies
in the world, are on call.
You and your little
cockamamie business are good?
Get outta here.
And so like, you know, that's it.
- It's a differentiator but what happens
for people who don't have
the time or the resources?
I mean I'm a working mom.
How on earth am I
supposed to do my day job,
talk to you, get home,
deal with my kids,
make sure that they have
enough to eat for the next day,
prepare their lunch, and
then use my remaining hours
to come up with something
that I'm passionate about?
- Well do you want to build a business?
- It's not so, I'm saying
for whatever I pursue,
and yes, if that means going
down that road later on.
- So I just think life's
about options, right?
Like everybody's got stuff.
Like to me the fact that
you even have the ability
to build a business between 9:30 p.m.
and one o'clock in the
morning is remarkable
because your grandmother didn't.
The internet has allowed that
to actually be even a debate.
Our grandparents grew up in an environment
where that became (clapping).
You know, you weren't opening
a business at 9:30 p.m., right?
The fact that we even
have the ability even
to debate that is fascinating to me.
And I'm not naive that there
is extreme circumstances
for many people and that people
are starting further along than others.
My point on that has always
been it's just remarkable
that you can do so much
between seven p.m and two in the morning
to change the outcome
of your life, the end.
And that's it.
I mean it's not super
difficult to understand.
It's the options that we are now awarded
by the infrastructure
of scalable technologies
that have no cost of entry
to build a personal brand
or a small business direct to consumer
is just fascinating to me.
You shouldn't, other people
have better advantages than you.
You're also more than welcome
to take a different job,
make less money, take a step back,
live a little less fancy for four years
and build your business.
The thing that we never
talk about is the step back.
A lot of people say to
me and they come at me
and they're like "yeah,
but I got this and this"
and I'm like cool but if you're so upset
and you want to build this business,
why not go from making 180 a year to 97.
You've opened up a lot of time.
Why don't you sell your home
and go rent an apartment.
Why don't you go fucking not
buy four different outfits
every month and buy one a year.
You can.
Life's about options.
There's a lot of ways to do this.
- [Scarlet] When was the
last time you stepped back?
- VaynerMedia's a step back.
- [Scarlet] How?
- How?
Seven years ago, I'd just
come on the back of investing
in Facebook, and Twitter, and Tumblr.
I was one of the 100 most
followed people on Twitter.
I had all sorts of opportunities.
I could have raised hundreds
of millions of dollars
for a fund on the back of being
an early angel investor that was fancy.
I was rolling.
I had a lot of things going for me.
And I decided to take a step
back and start VaynerMedia
because I thought it would
be an amazing infrastructure
for me to build on top
of in my 50's and 60's.
So I mean I make a lot less money
and eat a lot more shit
by running VaynerMedia
than the options that were
in front of me seven, eight years ago.
- [Scarlet] You took the boring approach.
- I took an extremely boring approach
that a lot of my friends that
are fancy still make fun of.
Definitely made fun of at the time.
Now a lot of them have
gone out of business
so they make less fun.
(audience and Scarlet laughing)
And you know what, to be very frank,
the Gary Vee thing started getting big
and I didn't like that I
was a motivational speaker.
I had so much pride that
as a 22 year old kid
I took my Dad's business with no money
and grew it substantially
at a very significant way
and I thought of myself as a businessman,
not as this personality,
or this new age motivational speaker,
so I think I even needed it for myself
to build another business
to just scratch that itch
that I wasn't a charlatan
or a personality,
that I had chops,
who just happened to be
a little narcissistic
and over the top.
- (laughing) For those
who have figured out
they're passionate, they
want to start a business,
they're ready to take the leap.
The question for a lot of them
is how do they tell that
story in a captivating way?
How do they convince others
that that they're there
and they're the real thing.
- For the purpose of raising capital
or for the purpose of getting awareness?
- Both.
- Well first you have to
figure out if you're capable.
Are you good enough at writing, audio,
or video to communicate your story?
You have to find your medium first.
There's a lot of people
that can captivate.
Fred Wilson has built
a lot of brand equity
and a lot of deal flow through writing.
Through writing.
I created it through video, right?
Joe Rogan and Tim Ferriss continue
to build it on audio, right?
So there's three ways to communicate.
When you start getting
into cartooning and art
you can go a little bit further
but there's three core ways.
There's written, audio, and video.
First and foremost you can't
be romantic about which one.
A lot of people want to be
good at video or this and that.
So A, you have to figure out
if you can actually tell a story
and then two, you have
to figure out the medium
in which you can tell a story.
And if you can do it in
more than one places,
that would be preferable
because our attention
is fragmented at scale.
So that's the strategy behind it.
- [Scarlet] So how do you
decide which is the best medium
because there's different
things that come into fashion,
go out of fashion.
I mean if you pause too
long, you'll miss it.
- My answer is to do them all.
- [Scarlet] Hit it all?
- If you can.
You know, look, I don't thing
people have really audited
how much downtime they
have if they want it.
I mean this all comes down to ambition.
Reverse engineering the actual ambition.
It's fine if you want to
pander in front of friends,
or relatives, or other people.
You need to really have a real
conversations with yourself
and you also need to realize
it's going to change.
When you're 22, and you're single,
and you're on fire, and your
older brother's killing it,
and you want to fucking
prove it to your parents,
and yourself, and this and that.
You get married, you fall
in love, you have a kid,
you have a sick kid, priorities change.
Life is life, a lot happens.
So not only do you have
to talk to yourself
and figure out what your ambition is,
you have to actually audit
that on a daily basis.
At least at a monthly basis
and it keeps changing.
It keeps changing.
I mean I took more days off this August
that I did in my entire 20's combined.
Why? Because I have an
eight and five year old,
and that's what's more
important to me at this moment.
And in my 20's I was so on fire,
I didn't want to go to the
Jersey shore and hook-up.
I wanted to build something.
And like things change.
Now I kind of want to go
to the Jersey shore, no...
(audience laughs)
I think things change
and I think that you need
to be prepared for that.
I'm must fascinated on words,
pandering, and actions.
I'm fascinated, I spend
a lot of time on this.
Because it helps people.
When you suffocate them and
tell them they're full of shit
or they're right, it's an
important conversation.
When you're tricking yourself,
you've got a real problem.
- Yeah, well you mentioned
how things change
and there are different mediums.
You could try to do all
three at the same time.
You're probably not gonna
be good at all three.
You'll be better on
one thing than another.
- Yes.
- The response that you get though,
it all comes down to
understanding human behavior
because that part doesn't change.
How people respond to a message.
- That's right, and I
genuinely believe the reason
that I've popped over the last decade
is I'm completely obsessed
with giving more to my audience
than I ask for in return.
Period, end of story, forever.
It's just the truth.
I really see a lot of faces here.
I feel a lot of vibes from you.
Like I'm not asking for anything.
I'm putting out the best stuff
I've got for free everyday.
It's not a top of funnel to
get you into my $400 ebook,
it's not a top of funnel
to get you to come
and visit my island for
$25,000 for the weekend.
It's fucking purely can I guilt you,
because I gave you so much that
I ask for nothing in return
that it creates word of mouth.
Can I be historically correct?
Can I just bring so much value?
It's ultimate brand arbitrage.
- Does it work?
- 100% because so few people do it
because they're not good enough to do it.
- [Scarlet] Give us an
example of when it worked.
- For who, for me?
- -[Scarlet] Uh huh.
- It worked because I made a video
that said Twitter's dangerous to Facebook.
It was a good thoughtful piece of content
that led to Zucks asking
me through Dave Moren
to fly out to Facebook
and talk to their company
when they were this size.
I talked about human behavior in 2007.
The whole time I didn't
know anything about Mark
and realized how much of an
EQ guy he really was too.
I didn't know he was
in the room like this.
He walked down from somewhere
over there when I was done.
He asked me if I could
have dinner with him.
We had dinner that night
and four months later I bought
a bunch of his parent's stock
and made tens of millions of dollars.
- Okay, that's a pretty good story.
(audience and Scarlet laughs)
- That's a good one.
Same with Tumblr, David
Karp saw a piece of content
about how I thought about engagement.
It led to a couple of drinks in the city.
Then he came out to Wine Library
and the B round of Tumbler
was $14 million evaluation
and I invested very aggressively
and made lots and lots of money.
I made a piece of content
about brands and Facebook
that Mike Lazerow saw, I gave him a quote,
for Buddy Media's landing
page when they launched
and I made seven figures
in advisory equity
for a quote on his website
on the back of a piece of content.
- Do you still own stakes
in those companies.
- No, I've exited all, right?
Tumblr sold to Yahoo, made money.
- [Scarlet] Facebook?
- Facebook I own every single share still.
I'm going to end up making
more money on Facebook
that some of the early top 100 employees
because I knew what Facebook
was when it went public.
- [Scarlet] You understood the mission?
- I think Zucks is an
all time entrepreneur.
He trades attention like I do
except he's way further along
and he can buy the companies
that are the infrastructure
but he stole Instagram, right?
I got made fun of for saying
that the day that happened.
He tried to buy Snapchat long
before anybody gave a fuck.
He invests in BR.
He moved a desktop company to full mobile
when it was painful and cost prohibitive.
He understands consumer behavior.
He is an extremely all time EQ operator
that people think is an introverted nerd.
- But he's also gotten a
lot of negative attention,
and Facebook as well.
The company's mired in
the government's Russian investigation.
- Yes.
- There's a lot of anger
towards big tech companies,
towards founders like Mark Zuckerburg,
who don't go through college
and now head up this big company.
They're billionaires.
The far left, the far right,
have kind of teamed up together
in their anger towards big tech.
- Yes.
- What's a road ahead for Facebook?
How does it navigate that?
How do you see the company surviving this?
- Easily.
- Or thriving?
- Easily, I don't know the details.
If they've done something horribly wrong,
they should pay the price.
But how do I see them surviving
it, pretty darn easily.
- [Scarlet] What about
all the public backlash?
- Yeah, easily.
Like everybody's using Instagram more.
People like to say shit,
they don't act on it.
Everybody here loves to
throw up some sort of tweet
and think they're doing
a social justice move.
Why don't you fucking
do something about it?
People talk, I mean it.
It's super important.
The day Uber was the worst and
everybody was unsubscribing
and it's terrible and I watched
four to five, six people
that I knew in my office and friends,
like unsubscribed, I hate it
and then literally, because I'm curious,
kinda like tagged it,
and then just watched them
take an Uber a week later.
(audience laughs)
We are so full of shit it's scary.
And all that big technology
is doing is exposing us,
not changing us.
And we're gonna have to go
through a painful 100 years
of understanding how full
of shit we really are.
- Do you think government
regulators will clamp down
on the likes of Facebook, on Google,
in a way that will change
how we interact with those platforms?
- I think it's possible.
I never underestimate politicians
because I don't respect them a whole lot.
- Do they understand the platforms?
- They may, or they may not,
but they will only behave
in their best interests.
So I'm not sure.
- You mentioned Uber.
- Yeah.
- I want to bring that up
because of some of the mistakes you made.
You passed up investing
in Uber how many times?
- Twice in the angel round.
Four million dollar evaluation.
- Maybe that's not so bad now,
given that they're kind of challenged?
- Yeah, I mean they're challenged
but it would have been a solid bet.
(audience and Scarlet laughing)
Yeah, it's an interesting time at Uber.
Travis is one of my dear, dear friends.
One of the first friends I made in tech
and it's been really intense
to watch what he's going through
and the thing with me is,
you know this is a tough interview for me
because the truth is I don't
even have the first detail yet
about Facebook and Russia.
I swear to God.
I know it's in the ecosystem.
I really don't like headline reading.
I really don't like it.
As I become educated,
as I'm super educated,
I'm really in a good
place in three places.
The current state of tech,
like consumer tech, right?
I really understand Snapchat,
and Instagram, and Musically.
I'm a practitioner, I
really understand it.
There's a lot of people here
that have opinions on it
and never done a Snapchat
ad or things like.
I really understand it.
I really understand wine.
And I really understand
the New York Jets, right?
(Scarlet laughs)
And when I hear people talk
about those three things,
even smart people,
I'm fascinated by when you're
really great at your craft,
how much smarter you are
than somebody that's even good, right?
I've gotten really quiet about most things
because I realize I might be
somewhat of a headline reader,
kind of a headline reader.
I've lost all oomph in the last five years
to talk about most issues
because I'm like wait a minute,
if I sound this stupid,
like the way my friends that
are super smart about Facebook ads,
and Instagram influencers, and Snapchat.
If I sound like this around
healthcare, or this or that,
I must, like so you know it's interesting.
The Uber thing's really
interesting for me.
I have a lot of emotions
cause I really adore him.
I understand there's a
lot of things in the press
that have been tough.
There's a lot of stuff
that's tough for me to,
like you know I'm hopeful, right?
When you care about somebody.
Obviously he's not there
anymore, which is tough.
It will be interesting to watch.
The London thing's super-fascinating.
I don't know the details.
I'm sure there's a lot
of politics behind it.
It'll be interesting.
It's an interesting company.
- You said you really understand Snapchat.
- Yes.
- But the problem with Snap is that
whatever innovation it comes up with,
Facebook can replicate it and
do it bigger and splashier.
- Yes.
- How do they go up against
a behemoth like Facebook?
- They have to innovate in
a way that is not a feature.
A feature is not the
way you innovate, right?
The cat's out of the bag.
Fast following features are
now going to be a way that
is not going to allow the house parties,
or the Marco Polo's,
or the next frontier
of things to get there.
So they're gonna have
to give it some thought.
What's ironic about that is Snap
is uniquely potentially a company
that could do that because Evan,
and I don't know him at all,
I've never met Evan,
and I know a lot of Imron's,
and a lot of the other characters,
but he's an L.A. kid.
He's treated Snapchat like a fashion brand
as much as a tech company.
He actually could go left field.
If I said to you that
it was Snap, not Adidas,
that did what they've done
for the last two years,
to put Nike in a weird spot,
it wouldn't seem that farfetched.
I get where you could be like mmm.
But it's not as far fetched
that if I said Twitter,
or Facebook, or Uber did that, right?
And so that's where I'm
fascinated what Snap
is gonna do or not gonna do.
We're about to find out if
Evan was a one trick pony
or if he could adjust to the
reality of the new marketplace.
They've quietly invested
very aggressively in AR.
You know, when you look at their M and A.
So I'd interesting to see if they can
or will do anything there.
And then the other
question is this, right?
Which is Snap is an
incredibly big platform
that can build a very big business.
It's just that the market
put all of the value in
to that it was gonna continue to grow
and be 30, 40, 50, 60 year olds.
So what's fascinating with Snap
is gonna be that it's probably over valued
in a Wall Street dynamic,
even amongst everything being over valued.
They're gonna have to do something.
They're gonna have to truly innovate
and it will be interesting
to see if they can do it.
But again, if Marissa buys
Instagram for a billion
instead of Tumblr,
who knows what could have happened, right?
That's what's amazing about business.
You're always one good
or one bad move away
from changing the narrative.
And I love that about this game.
Like I never get caught
up in it's going well
and I'm in this fancy building
and all these amazing people
are looking at me right now.
Tomorrow could be the
beginning of the complete end.
I love that.
Doesn't matter what
I've done for 20 years.
- How does Twitter change the narrative?
The user growth has
slowed down tremendously,
it's kind of become a niche product.
It's not panning out the way
a lot of investors had hoped.
It's now looking to expand
the character limit to 280 from 140.
I don't know if this is
gonna make a big difference.
- Yeah, that's not gonna be it, right?
(Scarlet and audience laughs)
I think we can all agree with that.
But I do think since Jack's back,
I mean look, and Dick is one
of my favorite people on earth,
but in that four years the
product didn't innovate once.
The product just did not innovate
and so at least since Jack's been back
for the last 18 months
or whatever it's been,
there's been little, subtle things.
I mean literally, and I know
there are a lot of people
in this room, like remember?
It was literally four or five years,
literally same exact product.
Even like start to heart, or like retweet.
Like little subtle things.
I thought it was superinteresting
what Twitter was doing
when they were buying up all the rights,
because I thought they
were actually building
a true Netflix competitor
as an OTT player.
I just don't know if they
have the right talent in place
to navigate it to be that,
but I thought it was the right idea.
I do think that Facebook,
and Snap, and Twitter
are absolutely the potential
OTT challengers of the future.
And I thought they were earlier
to move on that than the others,
but they needed to move
smarter, better, faster
and I feel like they didn't.
They just ended up doing
a six execution or a four,
instead of the 10 they
needed to rally get there.
- Do you think we're in a bubble
when it comes to these big tech companies
and how much money we're throwing at them
and what investors expect from them?
- I think Amazon and Facebook
are grossly under priced.
- Explain.
- I think Jeff Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg,
as long as they don't die,
are gonna make them grossly under priced.
- What's Amazon's next move?
- Being sued by the government.
(audience laughs)
Amazon is so incredible.
I remember four or five
years ago at a keynote,
and I don't remember if Steve Jobs
had passed away or was sick,
but I remember saying that I thought Bezos
was better than Steve Jobs
and I got really booed.
And this was the height of Apple.
And Amazon was four, five years ago,
which not what we think of Amazon today.
But AWS sawdust, like the way he bought,
like even the losses like
LivingSocial and Woot,
he was just doing things
and I was like fuck man,
Bezos has moves, right?
Like Steve Jobs is all time,
but he had the same move,
rinse and repeat, in a lot of ways,
if you understand how
I'm kind of framing it.
Bezos was throwing all sorts of different.
It was kind of like the
difference between boxing and MMA.
I was like Jeff, I think
he could do anything.
Like I woke up and Amazon buys Whole Foods
and I'm like yep.
- [Scarlet] That's us.
- Tomorrow if I wake up,
like Amazon buys the NHL,
I'm like mm-hmm.
(audience laughs)
I think everything is white space for him.
I think he is absolutely the guy.
I'm so impressed with their execution.
I'm so excited to watch them do more stuff
and I'm genuinely hopeful
that they understand
how to navigate so that the
government doesn't stop them
because they feel to me
more than any company,
as the company that could,
because I think they could
win the whole fucking thing.
They have the stack.
When you start understanding
that Alexa is this close
to becoming the next search engine.
When you understand that
you're brushing your teeth
and you run out of it,
and you're like Alexa reorder it for me.
When you start understanding
what they're doing
and the way they're putting
their pieces together.
When you understand
when you're watching
Thursday night football,
and Des Bryant scores a touchdown,
and at the height of your
emotion you can order his jersey
by saying Alexa order that jersey
or whatever they tell you
to do while you're watching
because they're full stack.
They are an unbelievably crafty business.
He buys under priced things,
buying the Washington Post at the time.
That Washington Post
and Boston Globe trade
at the time of newspapers biggest demise
the brand was so much more worth than this
to put it on the tablet.
Whether the fire worked or not,
it was irrelevant.
It was the right thesis,
and here's the thing
about great entrepreneurs,
whether Oculus is right or not,
it's the right thesis.
When you're a great entrepreneur,
and you're betting like that,
you just have to be right
once out of every eight times
to make the whole thing work.
Great entrepreneurs do not
care about their losses,
because they're their losses, right?
And average entrepreneurs
and non-entrepreneurs
always care about other people's opinions
about their losses.
- Good to remember.
Good to keep in mind.
All right, let's get to lightning round,
where I just basically have a lot
of random questions I want
to get Gary's opinion on.
What's the most overrated new technology?
- Consumer VR, and let me explain why.
For us right now as a practical function,
I believe in consumer VR,
I just don't think you're gonna see a lot
of consumers really
doing impactful VR stuff
the way you want to over
the next 36 to 48 months.
You still don't know a single person
that spends a good hour a
day in VR hardcore, right?
- Do you know anyone in the
tech community who does?
- Yeah, I'm sure there's
some hardcore people.
It's funny, the first
VR people I was meeting
like 18 months ago,
they were so nerdy.
I'm like, okay, this is good,
(Scarlet laughs)
like, these are real nerds again.
This isn't the club
promoters of fucked up tech,
these are nerds, you know?
So that was cool,
but I mean I really don't
even know of a story,
like it's not there yet.
So I think consumer VR is
gonna lose a lot of money
for a lot of people.
It's a great B to B thing.
It's great to go to the Superbowl,
and like do a brand activation,
but nobody's sitting at home
for an hour on VR yet for real,
and I don't think that's gonna happen
for another three, four years,
like real, and that to
me feels like overrated,
we all know it's coming.
I think in 20 years it
could be disproportionately,
it could arbitrage the
whole internet itself,
just short term.
I care about timing.
Timing's what matters,
and so not a fan right now.
- [Scarlet] Not a fan right now.
Who's a young and upcoming entrepreneur
that you're watching out for,
that could really be the next Jeff Bazos?
- I mean, at that level, I'm not sure.
I don't know if I've seen it.
- Okay, could be the next Evan Spiegel?
- So, you know, I don't have an answer.
I've also not been investing
a whole lot lately,
because I think the market
is grossly overpriced for,
I don't think ideas should be
worth four million dollars.
I'm a big fan of Rachel Tipograph,
the founder of MikMak.
I think she's a fuckin' gangster.
- What does the company do?
- She's pimpin' it six times
in the last 15 minutes.
(Scarlet and audience laugh)
It was originally mobile video.
It was was QVC for mobile,
then it became a SAS product
for brands, mobile integration,
swipe up shopability
in stories in Snapchat.
Her tenacity is intoxicating.
- All right, that's a name
that we'll watch out for.
- Yeah, I think that,
you know what's fun for me?
I don't think that name populates
for another seven, 12 years,
but when I recall this
clips on the internet seven,
12 years, it's gonna feel real good.
- Gary, Bitcoin or Ethereum?
- Ethereum.
- Why?
- Because it's more of a
platform than the singular brand.
It's Blockchain, then it's Ethereum,
then it's Bitcoin.
So I don't think people understand, right?
It's like WordPress,
and Netscape Navigator,
or Yahoo.com.
Bitcoin could win, and
could become a brand,
like a Nike, and could be amazing,
and all that, but Ethereum
is the infrastructure above,
which you build on top of.
Blockchain, bless you,
Blockchain is the most
gangster shit going on,
and I'll explain why.
If you truly understand the chess moves
of decentralizing everything,
well then the whole damn world's on call.
Governments included.
So, could be interesting.
- What's one brand that's doing everything
it's supposed to and more?
That's hitting it on all cylinders?
- I've never been able
to answer this question,
and let me tell you why.
I don't pay attention to other brands.
So, at Vayner,
when we have Budweiser as a client,
maybe my team, let me rephrase,
I hope my team for Budweiser
is looking at Miller Light,
and other things.
I think a brand doing
everything right means
that all their behaviors are
leading to a healthy business,
not more likes.
When Burberry, or Taco
Bell are getting all
the accolades in the press,
I never know if it's real.
I understand that it's moving quickly,
and doing good work on new stuff,
I just don't know if it's
actually driving business.
There's a big disconnect
between being innovative
and making business
decisions that are fruitful,
and so I'm not sure,
but I would say the ones that are spending
the least amount of money to make
the most amount of money in return.
(Scarlet laughs)
- Money out versus money in.
How would you advise,
let's say the NFL,
to reclaim it's glory?
It's under some pressure these days.
How would you advise it
to get its groove back?
Could it do it through social media?
- No. No, it's way,
way, way, way bigger than that,
and it's not concussions,
of President Trump,
it's so many variables.
First of all, fantasy football's dynamic
has been really intriguing,
because you've gotten people to care more
about players than teams.
You've got the RedZone channel
is such an incredible product,
like it's completely addictive,
like it's just a better experience
if you love the sport of football.
The man cave and the
high quality technology
has made it so much more interesting
to be home than go to the game.
- But even when you're at home,
people don't watch as
much as they used to.
- Yeah, I mean,
I think it hit a tipping point.
I mean, everybody like Jesus Christ,
it was like two years ago,
what the NFL has accomplished
over the last couple years
is iconic, all time.
It's got so popular,
and now soccer really,
the U.S. going to the sweet
16 of two World Cups in a row
is a very subtle thing that
people underestimate, right?
The distribution rights of
the English Premier League allowing kids
to watch in the mornings and
go with their dad at 7:00 a.m.
to do things is grossly underestimated,
Esports is fundamentally
being disrespected
for how big it actually is,
and all of this is chopping
away at the ratings.
It is still the disproportionate
most popular sport
in our country,
it's still doing incredibly fine.
I think it is laughable to diss the NFL
for their business issues,
and applaud Nascar, which has
become completely irrelevant.
- Which has seen its own ratings drop
over the years, long before.
- Nascar has fucking collapsed.
Nascar's down half.
Nascar's over.
Nascar doesn't even exist.
So it's like, if we're
talking the impact of stuff,
you know, that's a laughable argument
the President's trying to make.
Nascar's finished, Esports is coming,
and the NFL is where baseball was in 1984,
you know, or 1973.
It's like in that apex moment,
and there's only one way
to go from that level.
- How much closer are you
to your life goal of buying the Jets?
- Closer.
(Scarlet and audience laughs)
And closer because I think the way I play
is very different than Zucks,
or other people, which is
I don't do any behavior
that creates quick, massive wealth.
I don't do the things that
create quick, massive wealth.
I don't start companies
that can get to that level,
I don't invest the level of capital
I'm running a marathon.
A really long marathon,
but I'm 41 years old, right?
So to me, if I buy the Jets in 23 years,
I feel like I'm a young man.
I feel like I hang out with
a lot of 64 year old men
and women who feel super young with me,
and super on fire,
and have a lot more to do,
and I think if I buy the Jets at 64,
that gives me plenty of time
to win seven Superbowls in 30 years,
(Scarlet and audience laugh)
and then I could move on with myself.
- That's very ambitious.
If you can't get the Jets,
what's the next best thing?
- The Knicks.
(Scarlet and audience laugh)
- All right, the Johnson's
and the Dolan's need to watch out.
We're gonna open this up to
everyone in the audience,
because I know who guys all
have questions for Gary.
We have microphones, so
if you raise your hand,
let me know, and then this gentleman
in front will pass you a microphone.
- Thank you.
- [Daniel] So looking at industries.
- Which industry?
- [Daniel] Just in general right now.
- [Daniel] It's more
like an overall, yeah.
- I'm sorry.
- [Daniel] So you see
like Blockbuster totally ignored Netflix.
- Yes.
- And now, what's Blockbuster?
What other institutions
do you see, kind of?
- [Gary] All of retail. All of it.
- Yeah, so what advise would
you have for the Baby Boomers,
and the executives today
who aren't paying attention
to the tech companies about
what's coming tomorrow?
- Yeah, so Daniel,
I think it's a different conversation.
So, let him hold it for a second,
you're talking about those decision makers
at those retail companies
that aren't doing the
right thing to protect it?
- [Daniel] I don't think,
it's not just retail anymore.
- It's everything, I agree with you,
but what's the advice to
the people running them,
or the consumer?
I want to make sure I understand.
- [Daniel] To the people running them.
It's seem like right now they're
not listening to the Millennials,
and not listening to the upstarts.
- Yeah, it's not about that.
You know what it's about?
It's about the fact that
they are trying to milk
the next 24 to 36 months,
because their bonuses, and stock options,
and their life when their
done running this company
is based on what the stock
price is in 24 months,
so they can buy their yacht,
and their private jet,
and so what all these CEOs
are doing in public companies
is they're not being incentivized properly
for the health of the company,
and we're living through the
biggest culture shift we run,
because we're living
through a true revolution,
a true industrial revolution.
So what's happening is,
I am not mad at the Fortune 5,000 CEOs
because they're human beings,
and what they're doing is saying,
I'm gonna be in this world
for another 24 months,
I'm not gonna do the thing
that hurts the stock
price by over investing,
and having shitty PNL
to invest 100 million,
500 million in the thing that needs,
I have to put myself out of business
before somebody else does,
I'm not gonna do that,
because I'm gonna have
eight bad quarters in a row,
I'm gonna be on this network
show every morning saying,
I suck, right?
And then I'm gonna get kicked out,
and I'm gonna lose,
but Hershey's, or QuickGain,
or Hertz is gonna win.
They're not dumb, they're just selfish.
- It's about the short term.
- Pfft. I mean, why do big
companies go out of business?
Because Wall Street exists.
So, they know.
Way more than you think, my man.
They know.
They just aren't incentivized to do that.
- [Scarlet] This gentleman.
- They're gonna retire
with a lot of money, bro.
They're gonna retire with
a lot of money, right?
But if they listen to you,
they're gonna retire with less.
(laughter)
And that's why entrepreneurs
have so much opportunity,
because they're playing a different game.
Everything I do is for
the rest of my life,
for my legacy, for my family, for myself.
So I care about my business,
I care about my people,
because it's forever,
not I'm gonna use this as a stepping stone
to get on three public boards,
and da da da da da.
So, that's what's happening.
That's real life, everybody knows it.
Nobody talks about it,
but when I talk about it,
all the people shake their heads,
because everybody knows
that's what's happening
with every company that is trading,
and what this building
talks about all day long.
Every one of them do that.
It's fucking crazy,
but it's great for me
because it's gonna allow me
to buy great brands for
nickels on the dollar,
and I'm excited about it.
- [Audience Member One] Hi, Gary.
Thanks, big fan,
listen to you all the time.
Question, what are your
thoughts on AirBnB,
and home sharing, and the
future sort of lifestyle
of nomadic people visiting
different places, and so on?
- I think it will continue to grow.
I think Bryan's a really sharp CO.
I should also mention,
I co-founded a company I
haven't operated called Resy
that just did a fairly big deal with them.
Ben Leventhal, the CO,
and Mike Montero deserve all the credit.
I was in the idea phase,
and the capital phase.
So I hope he continues to do well,
because it's a big partnership.
What a big one.
I have an e-mail,
there's another miss for me,
got an e-mail from
joe@airbedandbreakfast.com.
Dear Gary Vee, I'm a huge fan,
we'd love for you to see our startup.
Never replied. Missed it.
(Scarlet and audience groan)
It's a good one.
- You read it though, right?
It didn't go into spam.
- I don't know.
Like, one of my assistants found it,
I don't know if I had
read it or not read it,
all I know is it happened,
and I've got in folder.
When Planet of the Apps launched,
and I was taking pictures with
those three famous people,
I went into that folder
and read all the things
I made mistakes of.
I love reminding myself
about those things.
It matters.
It's super interesting to me.
You know, you start talking to,
you start looking at the world,
there's a lot of arbitrages coming, man.
It's really interesting out there,
and like as social norms change,
the thing I'm most fascinated by
is how online dating went from
you are the weirdest nerd,
like what, to the absolute norm.
I can't believe how many well off people
would much rather have
their 14 year old daughter
go into strange men cars every day,
versus drive themselves.
I mean, if I sat here 15 years ago,
and said I'm gonna make you one promise,
because I like in the future,
all of you are gonna think it's more safe
for your 12 year old daughter to go into
a stranger's car every day than to drive,
you know, but that's our norm.
People of wealth send their
kids on Ubers all day long,
and so I think there's
growth in that category.
I think there's a lot of growth
in the ability of people,
arbitrage, Sawdust,
AWS, there's a lot of empty homes.
Right?
- [Scarlet] This gentleman here.
- Everyone has one.
Well, not everyone has one,
but you know what I mean.
There's a lot of fuckin' empty homes.
There's just a lot of empty homes, bro,
and a lot of empty a lot of things.
Lot of sawdust left to go.
- [Audience Member Two]
How you doing, Gary?
- That voice is incredible.
(Scarlet and audience laugh)
Have you thought about
monetizing your voice?
That's incredible.
- [Audience Member Two]
Yeah, I'm a speaker.
- What's that?
- [Audience Member Two] I'm a speaker.
- [Gary] Love it, it's a great voice.
Go ahead.
- If you can give me two power
moves to consumer attention,
because you have basically
mastered the art of video,
everybody and their mother watches you,
so if you give me two power moves
that you can use in the next 24 hours
to getting consumer attention,
what would they be?
- I would become
disproportionally educated,
or start practicing very aggressively,
in understanding how Facebook ads work.
Facebook ads are so good.
You can create long tail clusters
of 42 year old Latino women
that like the New York Jets, okay?
Now go make a video.
Go make a Spanglish video about the Jets.
Like, the ability for the
micro target and scale, right?
Like, you know,
I have a video that went berserko,
which was, it was basically,
I was getting mad that no 44 year old
thought themselves as an entrepreneur.
Like, I was watching all
the 19 and 20 year olds
with all these opportunities,
I was like, Jesus,
where are all the 40, 50, 60 year olds?
Like, have you heard?
You're gonna be living
longer that you think,
like let's go get ours, right?
(Scarlet laughs)
So I made that video,
and it went crazy because I
targeted 40 to 60 years olds
that watch Shark Tank.
You know, like there's so
much capability in that.
I also, you know,
look, I've got gift for gab,
you've got crazy voice, like you know,
you gotta be smart about that.
The first three seconds really matter.
The copy really matters.
The thumbnail really matters.
Everything matters.
I love how people think these people
that massed millions of
followers because they got lucky.
You know?
There's so much thought
that goes into what we do,
a lot of testing and learning,
but Facebook video.
YouTube is hard to break out. Very.
Facebook video, less hard,
especially if you have a
couple hundred bucks per video
to try to get it to go.
- [Scarlet] That's the first power move,
what about the second power move?
- For video?
- [Audience Member Two] Yep.
- Would you have interest
in people that are under 30?
- [Audience Member Two] I
want all of their attention.
- Respect.
(Scarlet and audience laugh)
His voice is so fuckin' rad.
Snapchat ads are grossly under priced.
$3 CPMs, they're watching a ton
of video once your ad comes in,
and you have to be very smart about
the first second to get them to swipe up,
and you can't say because
Snapchat won't show it.
You can get an unbelievable percentage
of people to watch three,
four minute videos in
a Snapchat environment
if you can get them to snap swipe up,
and you can get the most
people under 30 for $3 CPMs.
- [Audience Member Two] All
right, I'm doing that tonight.
- You got it.
(Gary and audience laugh)
- [Scarlet] This lady over
here, with the blue top.
Right at the, yes.
Thank you.
- Hi, thank you.
My name is Kirstin Broderick,
and I founded a company
called North Scale,
which is all about EQ.
I do executive corporate
and meditation training.
- [Gary] Love it.
- So if anyone needs that,
and if you wanna be the next Gary,
come check me out.
- That was a good right hook.
- [Kirstin] Hey.
- Go ahead.
- [Kirstin] My question
for you is you said
that Amazon might just do the whole thing.
- Yeah.
- [Kirstin] And this
is a two part question.
- Yeah.
- [Kirstin] What does that mean?
- Yup.
- And what does that
mean for the rest of us?
Not just the rest of us,
but the global economy,
the global society, the environment?
- What I think it means is
you think about the pillars,
or at least he pillars I think about
when I talk about this kind of stuff,
retail, media, right?
Social.
Like, I'd be surprised if Amazon wasn't
in the social business with
a real play at some point.
So those are three pillars
that really matter to me,
that I think about.
Like, media in retail is big, right?
If you think about how we live as a whole,
and I think that they,
Google's retail, and Facebook's retail,
everybody else's retail is so far behind,
it's nonexistent, right?
Their ability to catch up in
media has been far quicker
than the other people into retail.
So you think about China where,
full stack, they own it,
there's Communism dynamics there,
which is why it's possible.
So anyway, I just basically
think any business
that Jeff Bazos wants to get into, he can.
I really believe that.
I really think he could
buy the Hilton Group.
Whole Foods is the preview,
not the anomaly, right?
So if he wants to,
and I don't know him at all,
I don't know if his
space is more important
than being considered the
greatest entrepreneur of a time,
what it means to all
of us is the following.
There is a massive naivete
that we need government
to protect this issue.
It's called innovation and capitalism.
First of all, Jeff Bazos is gonna die.
Second of all, if VR
comes out in 16 years,
and hits full penetration,
if we're living in an
augmented world of VR,
AR, and real life,
well then the entire landscape
of VR opportunity becomes open,
it's internet 1991.
Everything he's built gets arbitraged
if the way we actually want to live
is have protein pumped into us,
and everything we buy is
actually happening virtually.
So I think there's a naivete
that anybody's ever gonna rule the world.
I really do, I really believe that.
Now, that's just how I see it.
You know, nobody's shown
me in the history of time
that they're gonna be able
to capture everything and sustain it,
because they get fat
and innovation kills them, not government.
That's how I see it.
- Gentleman standing in the back.
- I mean look, for example real quick,
just to put it into context,
I don't think it's ever been
a better time to be in retail.
Just go direct to consumer.
Amazon's got nothing to do with you,
and then people cry, you know,
Amazon's too powerful.
Don't sell it on Amazon.
You loved it when it got you
from zero to five million, right?
But now you're crying,
but how'd you get there?
So get in there, get what
you want, take it out.
Facebook, all these media
companies cry about Facebook.
Take people out.
People just aren't smart.
(audience laughs)
Really, like all these media companies
crying about Facebook.
Make all your content as a
customer acquisition model,
and then put them in your own bucket.
- Sounds so easy.
- It is easy, it's that,
once again, people that work in companies
are not incentivized the right way,
and it's just human behavior.
The end.
- Hey, Gary.
Thanks for coming.
My name's Rob Fajardo,
I founded a community
called Leave Normal Behind.
- [Gary] Great.
- Travel around, bunch
of different places,
and one of the questions I have for you
is as a Millennial,
being 23, your being 41,
how have you found the
ability to bridge generations,
and the personalities of
all those generations,
when it comes to assembling
a team for business.
- Yeah. First, by not
believing all the propaganda
about generational
behavior has been the way,
by one by one.
I know plenty of 41 year
old entitled lazy people,
and I know plenty of Millennials that
are working their fucking faces off.
One by one.
- [Rob] So just execution?
- One by one.
- [Rob] Cool.
- Right? I make no assumptions.
Like the thought that
Millennials are entitled
and any lazier than all my lazy buddies
that I grew up with?
No shot.
You know what I mean?
I think it's convenient talk, right?
I think your generation's the best.
I think you're the most advanced socially,
this, that, and the other thing.
Do I think a ton of you
got eighth place trophies?
Yes, and do I think that
that's why most likely
it's harder for your to beat me?
Yes, I believe that,
but not all of you got
eighth place trophies.
I mean, there was entitled
kids in other generations too.
So it's about strengths and weaknesses.
I think the biggest
undercurrent for the youth
is losing is a very good thing,
and we, the parents of these kids,
try to protect too much,
which has really hurt.
That's where America's vulnerable.
Like at scale, the political correctness
of winning and losing is a
fundamentally dangerous thing,
a lot more than I think people think.
Losing matters, and if
you don't get that gear,
you're in deep shit,
and entitlement is a real issue.
- [Scarlet] You're gonna
lose early and young.
- God, losing matters guys,
like fuck, if you're a modern parent,
and you're trying to protect that feeling,
you're being selfish.
You don't like seeing your kid upset,
I get it, I have them,
it sucks, but you better
fuckin' get out of the way,
because you're fucking it up,
because when you think you've won
when you came in eighth
place, that's fine.
When you manipulated their grades,
when you did their homework,
when you this that,
when you donated money,
and da da da da da,
when they get to the real world,
nobody gives a fuck,
and that's the cliche, one thing,
that this younger generation has worse.
It's definitely got, as a whole,
as a macro, that's scary to me,
which is why I'm going so aggressive,
because I have so much
of their attention
right now in this thing.
Like, it's good to lose,
I'm proud of my losses.
I am, I like it.
Notice how I talk about AirBnB,
like I want to bring up more,
I've got tons of shit.
I love losing.
I love the Jets, and the Knicks.
I gave up on the Yankees and
Rangers because they won.
I mean it.
It's a real thing.
I'm proud of my losses.
They're my losses.
What's your losses?
You've all got them.
Like this notion, and so that one
is big for everybody here.
You have to be proud.
I tried, at least.
People are O for O because
their too scared to lose.
I'll go for my three for 17.
(audience laughs)
- [Rob] Thanks, Gary. Appreciate it.
- You got it, borther.
- [Scarlet] This gentleman over here.
- [Dan] Thanks. Hi, Gary.
My name's Dan.
I'm an investor in New York.
- Awesome, man.
- [Dan] As a Millennial,
I wanna take umbrage with
one of your statements.
- Please.
- That I came in eighth
place and got a trophy.
(Gary chuckles)
I actually came in ninth, and got a medal.
(Gary and audience laugh)
- [Gary] Respect.
- So my question for you
is regarding executive compensation.
- [Gary] Yes.
- You were saying that
when you pay people with,
I guess, two years investing compensation,
they focus on the next two years?
- [Gary] Yes.
- If you were to pay them
in kind of longer term compensation,
what would you do to avoid
them basically goofing
off for seven years,
and not really having anything
to keep them in check,
you know, and saying no no no,
you gotta wait, you gotta wait,
it'll hit, it'll hit eventually?
- That's a great question.
I think that there's ways to find
a balance between those two probably.
I haven't really thought about it,.
Number two, I think that
there can be recourse.
You can take away equity along
the way instead of salary,
if they're goofing off for seven,
and make the big pay off in 10.
We have to.
If the biggest companies in
the world want to survive,
and the problem is the
board's in the same game,
so there's no checks and balances,
but if they want to,
if somebody has a motion for it,
we're gonna have to make
these much longer things,
and I think a lot of you
are in the game, right?
There's a whole kind of
conversation it seems
with some of the Silicon Valley talk
of like different compensations,
and different ways to go public.
I saw a headline, just haven't
started educating myself,
but it seemed that the energy,
Eric Ries for Lean Startup,right?
I saw something, I'm trying
to throw some stuff out,
somebody says yeah or shakes their head,
(audience laughs)
but it seems like there seems
to be starting some early debate of like,
it's not fun to go public
for Blue Bottle, right?
It was the Blue Bottle conversation
that it seemed started some conversations.
Nonetheless, yeah,
we're gonna have to start figuring,
I think, big companies are
gonna have to start figuring out
how to get into 10 year things,
and then the argument of like
then you're not gonna get the best talent,
I think it's the other way around.
You're not gonna get the best
talent by today's standards,
which I think are career CEOs that suck,
that are doing everything for themselves.
- [Dan] Cool. Thanks for the response.
- You got it. Thanks
for your questions, man.
- Final question.
This gentleman here.
- [Audience Member
Three] Hi, I just wanted
to follow up on that one.
- Please.
- [Audience Member Three]
Do you think other countries
are better than China,
either when it comes
to long term thinking.
Do you have concern that we're not,
as part of our global
competitive position?
- I'm not educated enough
to answer that question.
So that's the true answer.
I would just throw one thing,
as a boy that was born in communism,
you know, the China thing
is super fascinating.
I've run the gambit.
I've run the gambit of like,
we grossly underestimate communism,
and like it's weaknesses,
but the more I think
about what China's doing,
China's actually running the whole thing
a lot more like business are run, right?
Which is, it's a mix between dictatorship
and capitalism, right?
Like, there is an ultimate
collar at the top.
Like, it's really interesting.
It's been the theme in my
head the last six months.
I'm like, wait a minute.
You know, China runs China a hell
of a lot more like a successful,
like Bezos runs Amazon,
than the way we run America,
which is like, oh shit, you know?
You know, it's super fascinating,
so I don't know.
I really don't,
but I genuinely believe intuitively
that we are all very lucky,
because I think we're gonna live through
some really interesting times
over the next 20 to 40 years.
I think a lot of people hearing that
just exposed themselves to themselves.
Let me explain.
If you just heard that,
and you thought that was bad,
that means that you're a
pessimist and you're on defense,
and if you heard that and
you thought it was awesome,
it means you're an
optimist and on offense,
and I think most people
are defense and pessimist,
and I think that optimism,
and gratitude, and empathy
are the ingredients of the future winners,
and so I'm glad my parents gave me that.
- All right, Gary Vaynerchuk.
Thank you so much for joining us.
(audience applause).
- Hope you guys enjoyed that.
Question of the day before I sign off
and send you on your way,
what was the biggest insight
that you got from the talk you just saw.
I promise, I'm gonna read all 500,
600, 700 comments,
because this is the
insight I'm looking for.
So honest truths, what
was the biggest take away
from the talk that you just saw?
(upbeat electronic music)